Please welcome Chef Lenny,
the bearded dragon and his culinary partner
and owner, Valerie Musser.
Hey.
Thank you so much for coming.
I love it. Thanks for having us.
Oh, Chef Lenny, how did this cookbook come about?
Jeremy wants to know.
Well, so, Lenny was building a lot
of traction on Instagram.
People just loved all the food posts that we did.
We were doing national day calendar posts.
You know, everything is like National Pretzel Day
or National Cake Day or
all of these food things that are out there.
And people just, they really love those.
So we decided to put together a cookbook
with Lenny as the chef because there were no
at the time until Jeremy came along.
Lizard chefs, so it was perfect.
Well, Chef Lenny,
I wanna ask you what we're making today.
Today, we're gonna make
Ma's famous carrot cake.
And I'm Ma and now you get to be Ma, too.
Okay.
What do we do first?
So, first step is to grate some carrots.
We're just gonna grate some here.
You should have all your stuff.
Now, do you rec...
We're not gonna grate all of them.
We should, we need three cups for this recipe
so that's quite a bit of grating.
Okay. Perfect. So that's like the cute, sexy sample,
then we'll move this away.
Exactly.
And then we have
three cups of carrots right here.
We do, so just take your carrots and add it
right to your wet ingredients,
which you should have in a bowl
that has the pecans and the eggs
and the sugars and salt, and just dump it in.
This is just that simple,
and then,
stir it up.
Okay. So I've got all my wet ingredients together.
Then you're good.
We just move on to the next step here.
We're gonna add those dry ingredients, right on top
which is our flour, cinnamon, baking powder, baking soda.
Just dump it in, nothing fancy here,
and stir it up.
We just want it to be mixed together,
but not overmixed.
Like pancakes.
Just like pancakes
or anything with baking powder
it seems like, you know, you need to be, fold it in.
Okay. I'm good to go. Next.
Okay. Now we pour this into our pans.
Yup. Right into your prepared pans there.
Okay. Perfect.
Jeremy, are you listening?
And Lenny, what are your thoughts?
He's just making sure I don't screw it up.
He is judging my moves.
Chef Lenny, what's your favorite color?
My favorite color is yellow.
Really?
What sign are you, Lenny?
I'm a Pisces.
Hmm.
Lenny. Do you think I'm nuts? Hmm.
Yup. That's right.
Okay. So now we put the pans in the oven.
We do. We just put them in the oven.
Bake them at 325 degrees for 40 to 45 minutes.
And then you're good to go.
And since, you know,
we don't have a ton of time on our hands.
We've got our
finished masterpieces
Ta-da.
frosted with a cream cheese frosting
which is just cream cheese, sugar, oil, vanilla, and salt.
So now we have the cake
and we're gonna decorate it with edible flowers?
We are.
So,
okay, here we go.
Am I, do I just decorate however I want or however I?
Do however you want.
Sometimes if I make like, I was, you know,
and I am not a professional cake baker,
however, I love cake.
And you know, if you just arrange it
in a way that, I don't know,
your little flowers cascade down.
Ta-da. So you have a little spring cake.
It's just, the flowers make it so much...
happier.
This is so beautiful, by the way,
like, if I got this at a fancy bakery,
I would not question it whatsoever.
No. You'd be like, "That is legit."
Jeremy. Lenny. What do you think?
I think it's lovely.
Oh,
thank you, Lenny and Jeremy.
All right. Let's,
I'm gonna taste this now.
I'm just going right on into the cake.
(audience claps)
Thank you.
Cutting right in. Oh my goodness.
With an edible flower.
Ready? Here we go.
Here we go.
Here we go, Jeremy.
Ready?
I'm just gonna eat it with my hands.
Mm.
Oh my God.
I swear to God, I could eat this like,
I do eat this like three or four times a year
and it never gets old.
Oh, Valerie.
It's a cake.
Oh my God.
It's a spring cake.
Oh God.
That is so incredible.
You and Chef Lenny are so talented.
We're a good team.
Valerie and Chef Lenny,
thank you so much for coming on the show.
Valerie and Chef Lenny.
Go to the TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com for the full recipe.
(upbeat outro plays)